plus de quarante ans que la procréation
médicalement assistée divise la france
cette technique médicale soulève des
questions éthiques
on fait le point sur les partisans de la
paix m déjà en 1981 alors que les
détracteurs de la procréation
médicalement assistée craignent une
explosion de la pratique le biologiste
jacques testart à l'origine de la
première fécondation in vitro assure sa
défense il est évident que là on peut
pas parler de surconsommation ça ne
s'adresse qu'à des patientes qui sont
stériles et pour qui tous les autres
moyens classiques traditionnels de la
médecine ont échoué en vérité il y avait
à cette époque un vide juridique sur la
pma c'est en 1994 que la france se dote
de sa première loi bioéthique
l'objectif alors empêcher les femmes
ménopausées et les femmes célibataires
d'avoir recours à la pma
alors que des cas été médiatisée en
italie pour elisabeth badinter c'est le
début d'une atteinte aux droits des
femmes
on met le doigt dans l'interdiction de
procréer qui est une liberté absolue
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et que le surplus si
on commence comme ça alors après il
faudra s'interroger pour savoir si on
doit pas interdire à des femmes de 25
ans tout à fait saine du point de vue
physiologique et qui ont des graves
problèmes psychiques de procréer ou s'il
faudra pas interdire aux femmes
porteuses de sida de faire des enfants
et c'est raté
aujourd'hui seuls les couples
hétérosexuels peuvent bénéficier de la
pma à condition qu'ils aient tort
problèmes d'infertilité ou une maladie
grave transmissibles à l'enfant en 2012
en plein débat sur le mariage pour tous
il a été question de l'ouvrir aux
couples de femmes
je suis favorable à ce que
les lesbiennes puissent bénéficier de la
procréation médicalement assistée en
france que ce soit inscrit dans la loi
actuellement il ya une grande hypocrisie
puisqu'on sait que elles vont dans les
pays européens où c'est autorisé la
belgique n'importe où où on peut le
faire
la pma a été retiré du projet de loi
mais la revendication persiste elle est
scandé à chaque marche des fiertés les
repères de la société tout court même de
la société française vont pas
s'effondrer et que c'est juste un
progrès à la fois sociétale à la fois
médical pour pouvoir rendre des gens
heureux
en presque vingt ans la pma peu à peu
gagner les faveurs de l'opinion
dans le cas de femmes célibataires 53%
des français y étaient favorables en
1990 ils étaient 57 % en 2018
quant aux couples de femmes alors que
seuls 24% des sondés étaient pour une
ouverture de la pma en 1990 en 2018
ils étaient 60 %
[Musique]